Indian philosophy is a strategic
autonomy historically India also has a
long-standing leadership Russia India
has two hostile powers on its borders so
it's not a happy neighborhood
to take on security policy by DW here in
Europe the Russian invasion of Ukraine
is certainly still dominating the
headlines from the war on the ground to
how it's affecting the world order even
to the threat of nuclear war and the
knock-on effect that's hitting us the
hardest is the energy crisis exactly so
you had all of these European countries
rolling back their flow of energy from
Russia that they were so dependent on
for such a long time as part of the
western sanctions against Russia and
really in a bid to try and starve Russia
or starve the Kremlin of the resources
that it needs to try and keep this war
going which has only really had a
limited effect so far but if you look at
the global South the picture is quite
different I mean if you look at the
large countries there China India South
Africa these are the countries that have
actually refused to condemn the war and
in fact this is The Invasion because of
which tens of thousands of people have
lost their lives there's so many cities
there that are completely destroyed and
yet we have India on the other hand that
is buying more oil from Russia and that
too on discounted rates so would it be
fair to say that India is in a
roundabout way profiting from the war in
Ukraine because it's been able to buy
this Russian oil at cheaper prices right
now or if I could just put it in
different words is the war here in
Europe making the chapati in India
cheaper well that's the question that we
want to try and answer in the coming 30
minutes or so I'm Kate Brady I'm Isha
Patia Sanam and we give you a very warm
welcome to the very first episode of
DW's new podcast Global eyes on this
podcast we'll be taking security policy
out of the Realms of Academia think
tanks and government buildings and
breaking it down to find out exactly
what it means for you
you know what Kate I picked up my cup of
cappuccino this morning and it cost me
what four Euros exactly the prices here
they are skyrocketing and we are
experiencing this inflation at what
above 10 and everyone's worried that
they're going to freeze this winter and
at the heart of it all is energy or
maybe
thereof yeah which is interesting
because when you look at somewhere like
India right now when it comes to
inflation and the energy crisis they at
least seem to be faring somewhat better
right now yeah a lot of people seem to
think like that oh yeah because you have
this this chunk of energy that uh that
you know that Europe used to be buying
from Russia is no longer importing and a
lot of that is now ending up in in India
Russia's been looking around for new
customers and India's buying this oil
now at cheaper prices from Russia that's
right and if we look at the stats the
Indian economy is actually growing I
mean it hasn't seen a boom I wouldn't
put it like that but slow and steady
it's certainly going up and
um then again things are not as easy as
straightforward as a lot of people would
think like they are I mean overall the
prices of oil they have risen so it's
quite a strange situation where you say
the economy is rising but the prices of
oil they're also rising and there you
have the Indian foreign minister saying
that oil is actually breaking India's
back and so whatever good deals we get
we're just going to get them and hence
India's buying a lot of oil from Russia
exactly well I think that sounds like a
good time to maybe bring in our first
guest and jump straight in with some big
geopolitical questions she's going to be
our first of two guests today to help us
get to the bottom of all of this exactly
so let's have Seema sirohi she's a
renowned expert on India's Foreign
Relations FEMA is based in Washington
and she's a researcher for daily based
Think Tank The Observer Research
Foundation she's a columnist for the
economic Times Seema we are very happy
to have you with us welcome to globalize
how are you
I'm fine thank you and glad to be with
you thank you for inviting me Sima I'm
going to jump straight in with some of
the big uh geopolitical questions here
looking back in general I think it's
fair to say when it comes to foreign
policy India has always tried to keep a
distance in a way from some of the big
Powers but now that it's become this you
know even larger customer when it comes
to buying energy right now particularly
from from Russia
I wonder is India moving closer to
Russia at a time when a lot of countries
especially Western countries are trying
to distance themselves from Russia
no not at all I would dispute that
because uh if you remember the prime
minister of India said quite openly in
full public view that this is not an era
for war
India if anything is keeping sort of
equidistant from all the poles in the
world right now uh because uh Indian
philosophy is a strategic autonomy it
doesn't want to be in either camp and uh
that's what's happening remember that
India has a very long-standing
relationship with Russia uh in terms of
uh you know going back all the way to
the 50s uh when Russia used its uh veto
power in favor of India in the U.N
security Council on the Kashmir issue
then India has a very strong defense
relationship with Russia 60 to 70
percent of the equipment that India uses
uh comes from Russia this again is a
historical fact at a time when the West
was unwilling to sell weapons to India
India really had no choice so there are
a lot of factors in play uh history
doesn't begin uh today or when European
you know Powers decide that this is
important countries don't fall in line
that way they have their own National
interest
thank you now that brings me back to
um the recent comment of Indian foreign
minister Esther Shankar that he put it
very bluntly that Russia has actually
helped India when India needed it and
America was supporting Pakistan at that
time
so I've been following a lot of social
media trends and I see that there is a
lot of support with Indian people for
Russia but other than that I mean other
than this sentiment when it comes to
Kashmir when it comes to India Pakistan
Indians are always very emotional about
this whole thing but other than that do
you see there's anything deeper or is it
just on this level
that's pretty deep if you ask me if I'm
the prime minister of a country of a
billion people then that's pretty deep
reason then as I explained earlier the
defense relationship
um India has two hostile powers on its
borders East and West China and Pakistan
and China and Pakistan are in collusion
they have a very strong relationship
strong security relationship Pakistan
gained nuclear weapon designs from China
and became a really serious threat to
India and as you know India and Pakistan
have fought Wars India and China had a
War in 1962 so it's not a happy
neighborhood I think that's what
Europeans forget and kind of don't
understand that currently as we speak
thousands hundreds of thousands of women
Indian forces are in a standoff with
China Chinese forces On the Border so in
2020 China made several incursions into
India and 20 Indian soldiers were
brutally killed by Chinese forces so I
mean this is India's reality and as I
explained uh India cannot afford at this
time when it faces such a terrible
border situation where China cannot
afford to alienate Russia then there is
an extra reason it also doesn't want
Russia to go completely into the Chinese
camp
this the westerners understand to some
extent because they also don't want
Russia and China to be completely
aligned because at least for the United
States I live in Washington so I mean I
follow all this closely for the U.S
China is a strategic competitor
um and they want to have Partnerships
all you know with different Asian
countries including India India is a
bulwark of U.S policy uh in the
indo-pacific currently so there are many
reasons and all of them quite important
and significant I would say
of course none of us can see into the
future but I wonder just looking forward
what do you see India's role developing
into going forward we've just had the
the G20 Summit uh just in the last
couple of weeks as well uh the
presidency is now a bit of the G20 has
been passed on uh to India but even
though India was was present at the G20
Summit it seemed like that they're the
country's presence in a way was
overshadowed by uh not least of all the
meeting between U.S president uh Joe
Biden and China's Xi Jinping for example
I wonder is is there room there for for
India to really build up its role and
and build up its profile
yes it's a very very important
presidency and if you followed the
negotiations for the joint leaders
declaration after the G20 Summit Indian
diplomacy was uh you know recognized for
getting a consensus document through and
this qualified criticism of the Russian
invasion and Russian war against Ukraine
so that if you you know if you
see the Nuance nuances uh in what's
happening India is making it very clear
in the best way possible uh to Russia
that it's time to uh end the war so that
uh the countries that are suffering the
countries that are suffering the most
are the developing countries food prices
fertilizer prices uh Energy prices
they've all gone up nobody is benefiting
so it's not just Europe that you know
has this uh is suffering that the whole
world is suffering and India has been
engaged in a sort of backdoor diplomacy
with
um President Putin and the Indian Prime
Minister has talked to president
zielinski as well early in October so I
think the G20 stuff Summit that just
concluded wanted to show to the uh to
the Western World mainly that for
developing countries this is a very
important grouping very important
and
Indonesia which was the past president
India which is the current president in
Brazil the future president of G20 all
came together uh to bring out this
document because they didn't want
the summit to be dubbed a failure where
there was no consensus document coming
out so I would say a lot of things
happened yeah yeah I just came back from
the G20 and I saw India trying to have
this Balancing Act between the East and
the west and you've been talking about
this document and India has really
played a crucial role in uh wording that
document so that nobody gets offended
and everyone is at one platform you are
in the states how do you see the U.S
Administration
um how does the U.S Administration view
all of this
there has been praise for Indian
diplomacy from the White House
spokesperson yesterday there was a big
event at the Indian ambassadors house
and the deputy National Security advisor
was present he also praised uh you know
whatever happened at the G20 uh in
Washington what I'm noticing is that
even the Americans want the war to end
they don't want to force zelinski's hand
but they've been gently you know sort of
nudging him towards
um some sort of negotiation or some sort
of diplomacy that leads to ending this
war
so you just mentioned that there's been
a lot of praise for India so if I I just
want to understand this clearly is there
no criticism about India in U.S right
now that India is close to Russia I mean
we are sitting here in Europe and we see
this constant critique that why is India
not condemning Russia do you see that
kind of sentiment in U.S or is there
absolute no discussion over that
no there's a lot of discussion uh in
when the war started there was a lot of
criticism of India because India took a
neutral sort of neutral position and it
abstained on various U.N resolutions
there was a lot of criticism but then
um
Indian diplomats led by the foreign
minister did some major explaining
explaining and the U.S official stance
at least has become much more nuanced
they have said in every statement
they've made over the past three months
uh is that they understand that India's
relationship with Russia is historic
India's dependence for defense needs uh
goes back a long way India is
transitioning all these things have been
mentioned so yes there is criticism in
the mainstream media which is what uh
most people read
but if uh if you read the Indian media
you will see
many of these stories that I'm talking
about they don't get covered in the kind
of detail uh that gives you the full
picture I would say
right so if I may just bring you back to
our core question that we've been
discussing here
um we've talked about India China Russia
U.S and these are all very complicated
issues when it comes down to the common
man so when it really boils down to the
common man and their needs does this
whole conflict really have any effect on
the Common Man in India or on the common
Man's Pocket for instance
absolutely the price of oil the price of
gas the price of food fertilizers the
farmers are hurting so you know
everything has an effect on the Common
Man and if the Indian government's
responsibility to provide uh energy
right so for the economy not to tank uh
if you see India's neighborhood you you
saw what happened in Sri Lanka there are
fears that uh similar things might
happen in Bangladesh protests on the
streets governments in danger riots on
the street because people don't have you
know uh gas in their fuel tanks so yes
it's a very real thing
um
same thing is happening in Africa so the
developing world is actually hurting
much much more than people recognize and
that's the I think also part of Indian
diplomacy to give a voice to the global
South
to give uh you know articulation to
what's going on in the world that
normally doesn't get that much attention
in your opinion is there enough
attention given by the general
population in India towards what's going
on internationally
in terms of you know how so that people
can better understand the impact of
foreign policy and security policy
you mean whether the Indian people
understand that China is a great threat
to their security yes they do understand
um if you look at surveys uh you know
earlier uh in the Indian people were
more concerned with Pakistan but
increasingly they they cite China as the
major threat because of what happened in
2020 On the Border
um and that standoff continues it's uh
you know two years that it's going on
and 16 rounds of talks have taken place
with no
um with very little progress so yes
people understand uh what's going on
um in terms of foreign policy and the
Ukraine war is a very real thing because
it hurts uh them sort of directly
but but trade with China that still
continues despite the conflict right
yes and uh um that's a very good point
and in fact the trade uh is rising
because decoupling as I think uh people
in the west know as well decoupling from
China is going to be very tough very
long if at all it happens because China
is the world's Factory it has had 20
years to become that every major economy
in the world is dependent on China
Supply chains many many of them are
centered in China so uh but there is a
move away from that it'll take a while
it's not happening tomorrow
thank you so much Sima that was really
really insightful thanks for putting
things in perspective and for your time
thank you thank you
thank you Kate you know what I found
really interesting was that Seema made a
mention to prime minister Narendra
modi's code that this is not an era of
war and this was actually something that
he had said in the SEO Summit and that
was later picked up for the G20 final
document and there you see that again
India is underlying its non-aligned
stance that it does not want to be in
any camps whether Russia or U.S or any
other Camp let's say but as she has put
things in perspective for us that India
cannot afford to lose Russia and there's
these historical ties and so India will
continue to buy oil from Russia and it's
important yeah and I think this is that
the the sense of this Balancing Act and
she said that the the India is trying to
keep itself kind of equidistant from the
East and West right now which has its
long history but I think that is going
to be really interesting to watch how
that develops in the in the coming years
as well especially with the situation
with China and I think what makes the
the position really unique with with
India as SEMA was telling us is is how
so many of of India's domestic issues
for the rest of the world could very
much become huge foreign policy and
security policy issues as well so
certainly this Balancing Act uh really
certainly is going to get more more
complicated I feel like that's right and
talking of domestic issues as you said
what I'm really interested in finding
out is that how does all of this really
affect the Common Man I mean coming back
to our core question whether it's going
to make food prices cheaper whether it's
going to make the chapati cheaper and to
understand that let's have our second
guest that's nandike Shiva lingam he is
the director of Center for research on
energy and clean air that's a think tank
that's based in Helsinki and nandakesh
has been working on coal and power
related issues in India for over a
decade and he has loads of expertise and
policies and politics around energy
sector in India you're joining us from
Bengaluru today thank you so much for
your time welcome to Global life it's a
pleasure to be here
so everyone's talking about the war in
Ukraine and whether India is taking
advantage of the situation there and
that's also what we would like to talk
to you about today exactly and a lot of
people are asking as well whether it's
really morally correct to continue trade
with Russia following the invasion of
Ukraine or in the case of India for
example expanding trade with Russia so
before we get into the details of that
maybe you can just give us a pinpoint a
few basic facts for us where did India
get its energy Supply from before the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and what has
changed since the war
so to put it in perspective uh India
still gets this majority of its oil
supplies from non-russian sources right
look at volumes that comes to India
through Russia is a minuscular amount uh
2.4 percent even uh the latest it was uh
1.7 before last year so therefore that's
the perspective that needs to be uh
first in terms of when you look at what
is India's actually up to uh with uh
with Russian oil buying what would you
say is the main incentive for India to
really step up as this huge Energy
customer right now we hear a lot about
these discounts obviously Russia has
been looking around shopping around for
new customers as well what's the real
incentive behind that is it just uh the
is it just the case that there are
discounted prices and India's making the
most of that while it can
yeah
so the need to go for Russian oil came
from the fact that uh when the war
started the prices of oil shot up
drastically right India being a energy
challenge country where we don't produce
most of our oil it's all imported that
pinched India's pocket so the the need
to go for Russian discounted oil was
kind of out of necessity to keep
inflation in check and to consider you
know price sizes for Indian citizens so
so the underlying factor is it is a
challenge uh morally to to the entire
world in terms of how do you deal with
that crisis but most con almost all the
countries went about are still going
about deciding what to do with uh
Russian fossil fuels uh based on its uh
practical issues that it's facing
domestically with respect to prices with
respect to availability and things like
that so India also took a similar route
in terms of trying to manage its
domestic cost uh to keep costs down
therefore it had to you know it had know
the choices what I would say in this
case
and I just wonder I mean the headlines
here for you know almost a year now of
course have been filled every day with
the latest headlines from Ukraine you're
in India right now I wonder do what are
the main concerns are is anyone
concerned really about the war in
Ukraine is that still a big issue
So within people's mind it's any word is
concerning right people uh life's lost
is uh for for peaceful reasons uh is
always a concern but if you look at in
terms of the day-to-day
discourse in the country whether Ukraine
is the main topic definitely not I think
India has a lot of issues with respect
to domestically as well as in the
neighborhood where India is trying to
sort out many challenges therefore it's
not the top agenda but definitely it's a
concern that you know Indians as well as
the government has
then let's actually talk about the
things that really matter to India like
you said it's not a discourse in India
and what really matters to the Common
Man the ahmadni as we say in India is
um Kate if I may just say three words in
Hindi it's a roti kapra makan that's
what we say Roti is chapati
um basically food kapra is cloth and
Macan is where you live so you've talked
about inflation you've said that it's
come out of necessity that India has to
buy things has to buy fuel oil because
it has to keep inflation in check so
directly talking how is this this buying
of oil from Russia how is it directly
affecting the Common Man there see like
if you look at historically it will get
last couple of years India's uh prices
of uh like oil specifically has gone up
right during Jazz as well so
like the volume of whatever oil that
India is buying from Russia uh is used
to the because the price discounts and
other things it's used to keep uh like
you know run away prices of fossil fuels
at check to some extent but that doesn't
mean that India's prices has not gone up
this yet it's shot up to almost from one
dollar uh a later to now 1.3 dollars
later so it has still pinched India
right thank you for putting it in
perspective so basically what you're
saying is that India or people in India
are not really profiting out of uh the
trade from Russia or the way it has been
put that this is sanction and yet India
is continuing trade so India does not
continue to profit out of Russia in that
way
see it's again I'll go back to the
inflation argument right so India Indian
government has uh to take certain
measures with respect to keep keeping
inflation at no uh at a minimal level
it's around six seven percent right so
they think uh losing some part of it uh
through the buying discounted oil from
Russia would you know keep give some
relaxation in terms of you know having
that check so that's definitely one
aspect in terms of why uh it you know
India is doing uh purchasing of Russia
at necessity but historically India also
has a long-standing leadership with
Russia where they cannot and will not
take decisions drastically as you know
other countries may or may not take
therefore that so the current
necessities of you know inflation and
the energy security for the country
coupled with what historical India has
been having as a relationship with
Russia defense and many other things uh
would be two primary you know criterias
how the government would look at you
know what steps they should be taking so
we've touched briefly on inflation now
I'm just wondering if we can shift maybe
to energy you talked a little bit
already about energy security
India of course now as well Major Force
in the global energy economy as well and
of course the demand has been growing
symbiotically as the population grows as
well and I imagine that that's only
going to increase in the coming years as
well
but I wonder the way in which India is
now deciding to buy more or invest more
in Russian fossil fuels does that not
risk making India more dependent on
Russia for its energy something that
Europe for example has experienced
firsthand and really felt the the bite
of you know now that they've had to wind
down their flow of Russian energy since
the war in Ukraine
so two aspects right one is uh
Russia was not conventionally
conventionally an exported to India
again I said like what it was 1.7 before
the war it's gone to three percent uh
plus or minus right so that's a small
volume for India to be dependent on
Russia uh assuming that you know that's
it remains at that level so the volumes
are too small to say that there would be
a dependency Creator right uh but on the
other hand it's only a small volume on
oil unlike so India does not have much
dependency on gas uh India definitely
has enough coal reserves for receptor
demand so therefore it would never be in
a situation where Europe is where the
dependencies are much much greater
so therefore I don't see that as an
issue where India becoming independent
on Russian prostitutes on the other hand
India also is investing heavily on
renewable energy sources so so that's
going to be one of the key primary uh
driving factors with respect to the
electricity Market uh in the next uh
decade or so where India would look at
diversifying even from coal and other
sources so that you know it's there's
not there's no dependency on one
particular source so I think that's the
message you know globally that you know
that we try to communicate that putting
all X in in the fossil fuel bucket uh
has led to you know the situation then
there's definitely a need to diversify
uh and then look at [ __ ] as well
mainly clean ones but since you're
talking about Renewables here
um I mean even if we were to keep Russia
and Saudi Arabia aside
is it possible for India to get
completely uh independent in the next
decade or couple of decades let's say
when it comes to energy
so uh with respect to electricity where
the dependencies on uh on coal domestic
coal and to some level of import coal uh
in it by 2040 is definitely possible
because the renewable energy markets are
well Advanced therefore I don't see why
that's not uh can be achieved whereas
India needs to progress is on oil where
the alternatives are now emerging with
respect to electric vehicles improving
public transport and things like that I
think there's a lot of work to be
happening so I don't see uh like there
needs to be a lot of work put in uh to
move away from you know oil specifically
uh but I think India is in a reasonably
good enough track I think this crisis if
at all it has done you know uh the The
Silo lining of the test it has it's
accelerating the clean energy transition
across uh the world mainly I think India
would also see it as in that light and
then you know push your better policies
uh to you know to kind of keep its
energy secure
and what about nuclear energy the
argument is that it is of course cleaner
as compared to coal
it's definitely cleaner than coal I
think different countries have different
viewpoints on uh on nuclear energy right
they for India it has been the main
concern has been safety right and still
at least in my opinion uh we have not
cracked the safety uh discussion because
of the population density and where
these nuclear power plants are located
so so those are and and it takes sheer
uh at decades to build nuclear power and
it's also more expensive than renewable
energy so if if all these things are
stacked against nuclear I don't see that
you know uh you know growing in a bigger
way
so to wrap it up you've been talking
about inflation
I found it very interesting that you
said that what we what India is buying
from Russia is actually just a very
small chunk and that will not really
make much of a difference but at the
same time you also said that India needs
to keep buying from Russia to keep
inflation in check so these are like two
things for me that don't really come
together so well if you could just uh
put that together like how do these two
things really relate to each other and
coming back to our core question if
that's going to keep inflation in check
our question was whether it's going to
affect the price of chapati I know when
we talk about inflation in India we
don't really talk about chapati as such
it's about the cooking gas cylinders or
the onions but symbolically speaking is
it going to really make difference to
the common people
if you could just
uh sure so this is how it is right so
instead of buying your 100 of your oil
uh from an already higher uh price
market right now you buy say 95 of it
and it is five percent you substitute
through discounted oil which is 30 30 25
35 substituted that would mean that your
overall cost is still less than what you
would otherwise would have paid right uh
now the question is whether that would
make a significant dent on inflation
itself uh to some extent yes but to a
large extent uh not because inflation is
not only a price a fossil fuel ratio it
has a lot of other uh parameters which
you know the government you should check
thank you that was very insightful thank
you so much for your time
thank you very much
so we've had Russia we've had India
we've had the U.S China Europe I think
it's fair to say we've covered quite a
bit of ground with our two guests today
lots to digest right
So after talking to see my nandikesh
what are your takeaways well I think one
of the main words that stuck out to me
from both of them into very different
areas was dependency so on the one hand
you have these huge domestic issues that
India is trying to you know deal with
right now not least of all when it comes
to the rise of China but that struggle
of trying to reduce its dependency on
China something that Europe is facing as
well right now not least of all Germany
and kind of reassessing its economic
ties with China but also that applies to
um to the energy situation as well we
had there from from nandikash about the
the needs to diversify not only for you
know in terms of climate protection but
also as to come back to Europe you know
Europe has learned the hard way that it
became far too dependent on Russia and
so though it was interesting to hear
that there is you know a bit of a risk
right now that that India could find
itself in a similar position if it
becomes too dependent on Russia so I
think you know we we throw this term
around quite frequently about you know
the shift of the of the world order but
it's really these these shifts in
dependency
um are really going to keep changing in
the in the coming years and I think
that's going to be a real challenge for
India especially when it comes to to
this Balancing Act this geopolitical
balancing act that it's still keeping up
at the moment between East and West
that's right but you know what I found
really interesting was that nandikesh
mentioned that
um the total amount of import that India
has from Russia is still minuscule and
so here's saying that India would still
not be as dependent on Russia as others
are fearing and we've actually been
talking a lot about whether what India
is doing is morally correct or not ever
since the war broke out since February
we've continuously been listening to
this that India should stop having trade
ties with Russia and if you look at the
numbers they've actually gone up like
anything it's a rise of 300 percent
which is huge but like not the case had
put it if you really look at the
absolute numbers it's still not as much
as the EU is doing or I mean sitting
here in Germany even the trade that
Germany has with Russia I know we're not
going to have
um Russian gas now so the winters are
going to be difficult but when it comes
to India India is not going to stop
having trade with Russia because one it
needs it two it's still not as much as
the EU and another thing that I found
really interesting was and I think
that's my takeaway that Seema mentioning
China and saying that despite the
tensions between India and China India
will continue having trade with China
which I think in the whole geopolitical
scenario that's really interesting that
on the one hand you have this tension on
your border area
on the one hand you have your people
hating the others and there's this
constant discussion of
um you know that we have to boycott
China I mean I really see this a lot in
social media where people are saying
boycott China don't buy anything that's
Chinese but the government continues to
have trade so the government can't say
boycott China because the trade is
important and in fact China has become
so important you can't just say boycott
China and then we're going to get your
smartphones from well but that's a
completely different area that we can't
get into right now on our podcast and so
coming back to our core question yes the
economic impact right now is the war in
Ukraine making the chapati cheaper well
it doesn't really look like it not in
the long run at least
so that's all we have for you on this
episode of globalize if you liked it do
subscribe on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts and let us know what you
think about it and if you have any
questions for us here at globalize about
how security is or could affect your
life let us know you can send us an
email at globaleyes dw.com thank you
bye-bye bye